um 80 of women choose 20 of men when
they're asked about their Idol partner
right so 80 of women there's a pool of
20 of men roughly right who women want
okay so eighty percent of women are
dealing with 20 of men and that's the
reason why women think that men are
trash because those 20 of men have 80 of
women to choose from so they're going to
exercise a lot of them are going to
exercise those options with those 80 of
women so a lot of the time when you were
saying oh the men that I dealt with are
trash you're dealing with trash men yeah
of course right okay so when you say the
majority of men are trash you said the
majority of men are trash but it's not
just my experience no but the majority
of men are good men
the majority of men are good men but you
don't you don't want that like one one
and three one in three men or either
virgins are having had sex in the past
year if girls wanted a guy that could be
faithful they could find one but that we
don't want them so for if we're getting
cheated on it's literally our own fault
because we picked the guys that can get
a bunch of girls
check your comments wait are you on
about like man in the UK won but one of
the Western World the western western
worlds one and three that that was sorry
they're either virgins or have it under
30. one in three men under 30 or either
virgins or haven't had sex in the past
year so what I'm saying is like a lot of
times girls will say things like men are
trash men cheat but literally like only
five to Fifteen maybe twenty percent of
men can cheat so if we're picking the
guys that cheat how can we complain when
we get cheated on you picked them
because why would we pick men just
because they don't cheat we want men who
don't cheat who have a good job if you
have everything else today right but
yeah you don't if you if you want if you
wanted them you would pick them they're
they're guys but there are guys that
have good jobs that don't cheat you
could get an engineer you get a computer
software
engineering there were 50 guys that you
walked past today didn't even notice
you know those regular guys the guys
that work at Starbucks the guys that are
taking the bins out the guys there's a
guy in my front security desk you said
well you you literally walk past 50 guys
today that you did not even care about
because they didn't match that top 20 of
men that you're looking for so why you
should we have to sacrifice the rest of
what we want just because he doesn't he
doesn't cheat why does why does the top
have 20 have to cheat that doesn't make
sense just because I have everything
else I don't have to cheat like you're
asking me because I think you're living
in a fairy tale because you're you lived
in a Disney princess world that's told
you you can have everything you don't
get to have everything I don't think but
I'm saying I'm saying men and women both
have to compromise on things that they
want they probably want want girls that
haven't slept with a million people but
that's not really common in the western
world
what's the age category of the men that
you're approaching because if they're 30
over they should be much more mature
than being trash I don't think age makes
a difference it does it men 100 percent
million percent men underdeveloped if
they do not get taken care of 100 every
single male is underdeveloped if they do
not get proper fathering and then they
grow up in a man's body that can kill
people and then they go out become
neanderthals and their minds are
children there you go there you go so
are you saying that um in order for a
man to be a proper man a good man uh he
needs to be raised by a mother and the
father 100 yeah definitely I believe the
idol situation I believe is for a man to
be raised by both parents but uh but but
more importantly I think one of the most
important things for a boy is to have a
male Father Figure in their life and we
if we're talking about this we're
talking about the subject today if you
look at the media and you look at TV
shows and you look at what is portrayed
as a father figure right in TV shows and
stuff like you look at The Simpsons you
can look at Family Guy family okay right
these are bumbling idiots they're
bumbling guys and it's normally them the
women in the relationship which is the
Smart Ones and they're like oh we know
the guys are stupid and it's like oh I'm
just gonna be a bumping idiot and just
grab a beer and go and do that is a that
is what women and men and young boys are
being shown what a father is and I think
the masculinity when it comes to
fatherhood has been removed from society
which is why we have such a problem with
the young males it also helps to know
all devices is available at your
disposal the negative Vice if you know
all of it you can prevent your child
succumb to that Vice that's important
before it becomes the degenerate it's
easy to become in contemporary Society
100 years ago we didn't have much to do
it was easy to be raised by a village if
your father died your father dies now
you're selling crack
you're selling crack right now you're
not goats so um I want to go back to
something you said when you said um you
think the majority of men did you say
bad or you said the majority of men are
something no I said the majority of men
that I had experienced the trash but you
did say the majority of men are trash
okay so so question yeah do you do you
also feel like the majority of women are
trash
yes okay so you feel like it's equal you
just think about are you are you
included in that category definitely
definitely
isn't that highly convenient right now
but
but not all men are trash I've come
across a lot of really good nice guys a
lot of my friends that are male I
wouldn't put them in a category of men
are trash but the experiences a lot of
experiences why don't you date them
because they're not physically my type
it's not their personality it's just
that I have a friendship with them right
and I'm not physically attracted to them
but you assume they are physically
attractive it's not my type right but
you see what I'm saying like there are
guys that would treat you well in your
friend zone
no no this was before so since since
I've changed like if I came across a man
that was everything I wanted a good job
like respect for all those things 100
I'll go through I'm not looking for red
flags I'm too old for them like I'm
literally 24 like this is the age or I
want to be wifed up I don't want to be I
don't want to be with a red flag I know
you think all women will love red flags
like that's it I don't think all women
like red flags I think women are
attracted to red flags yeah but I think
that's immaturity to be attracted no I
think it's just honest I've Got a Theory
on this that I've I've worked on for a
while I I think of I can perfect it so
my idea do you need a whiteboard yeah
she's got a white one I saw that one
yeah I'll just articulate as much as I
can so
I I I work in the in the nightlife
industry security industry so I'm I'm
kind of privy to how sexual Dynamics
worked
um a lot of the times and I see what I
see from personal
um observation
you're seeing a lot of girls a lot of
young pretty girls getting with
the dealers
the Drillers
the
fraud Stars
everything that
in some so some way these kind of guys
gather for themselves in a holistic way
so what I mean by that is
these guys display a sense of economic
wealth money
number two they explain they
they exude an aura of somewhat power
these are the individual things that
young girls are attracted to all women
by that but the thing was with these
these men these men are normally getting
it very young at age but they're
displaying things that a man normally
works to at the average age of mid 30s
40s and what about me what I mean by
that you get a footballer for example I
work in the sports industry as well so I
see this firsthand
a lot of the things that they get comes
very quickly well Fame status
by 1820 right you could be famous
they would have a flock of women at
their disposal
but the average man doesn't attain to
the status until he hits his average
averagely mid 30s to 40s so some of
these men are displaying what it will
normally take an established man to have
very young at age but what women fail to
realize that these guys are still boys
right they've not matured to a level
where they can understand
uh the power that's given to them stay
as wise and how to deal with women and
it's like blocking a man from a sweet
shop all his life and allowing him he's
gonna go crazy there's no boy I can I
can relate to this at a young age when
you're afforded the ability to to be
attracted to women
you don't know how to handle it at times
so women get with these type of guys and
complain why is this happening but they
don't know a lot of these men who attain
this somewhat Street Fame and a
financial uh
status they don't know that this comes
short for a man and say he's early 20s
to these type of people but they're
still kids so then what type of father
would that child or that young man
normally that goes on to my point of the
subject normally these guys are
fatherless because
um from antidote and personal experience
I know guys like this you know growing
up with guys like this and I see it and
probably up until this day I still see
the fact that
when you're when when there was a lack
of father when there is a lack of father
in the home
um you don't have a good example you
don't have a example so to speak of how
to be a man
a child looks at his father I remember
the way I used to look at my dad growing
up and he was everything I wanted to be
once you get into a certain age but he's
traits rub off on you he's work ethic
he's disciplined he's Authority he's
masculinity he's manhood when a boy
doesn't have that at home he finds it
elsewhere right he finds it in community
he finds it on the streets because every
child is looking for a thing every child
is looking for father in females and
males and when men don't get their own
they find it elsewhere and unfortunately
so do you think there's a lack of
masculine good steady
father figures right now absolutely
absolutely do you think that's do you
think that's what's portrayed or you
think that's real life it's portrayed
and it's real life you gave the example
of The Simpsons I grew up with Tim
Simpsons and
I remember seeing home as funny as he
was this wasn't my dad you know
personally and this wasn't my father
figure he was just a comedy ass but a
lot of people see this especially for
the ones who don't have dads they see it
they grow up on it although it is
comedic it is an example of how men are
portrayed in in society and when they
grow up without uh such a male figure uh
that that they can look up to
you get what you get as many of you know
I was just banned on Tick Tock and we
are demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible